this dude is building his
own house what is happening
look at this it's beautiful
you're good yes man wow look at this
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel lee's i'm
standing in the beautiful area of upsell
paul up till hollywood obstacle hall i'm
with my man leon
melissa these guys are awesome and
literally we met like
just over a year ago yeah 2019. and you
were saying to me haven't made the wrong
decision
yeah i'm buying this piece of land yeah
and it
and and i said it was a good decision
yeah you said that the maps are
bro it's a good decision to add up it's
a good decision do the maps add up of
course they do fact come here come here
quickly can we have a quick quick look
around
all right come on real quick okay so
this is it now this is this is like your
dream home right
yeah this is something you love melissa
yeah melissa loves it
five bedrooms i don't know why they've
built a five bed house when they were
where just the two of them yeah what was
the purpose to sell it one day maybe
yeah it was just a thought of maybe if
we were going to resell it obviously
five bedrooms it ticked all the boxes to
for a good resale
if we were to do that yeah and this one
they're building next door
yep um you know they're building all
around here you can literally see what's
the name of that
rosary top and it's a famous view for
around this area rusby-topping it's
called
rosemary topping yeah quite cool
oh my god this is so good isn't it yeah
well with me we're a bit too keen on
this bro we've not put the door frames
in yet
yeah so they're actually going to come
out a lot oh wow i love it
it's such a satisfying feeling isn't it
how
so you're gonna have some swirly stairs
where will they be then but they've got
here
so believe it or not this is gonna hit
please wear them
um right you have to remake them
obviously that would be the finished
[Music]
these two features this area was uh
again
yeah you know you you've got an
emotional attachment to that bad
thing to do but yeah it's a totally
different thing
and it's also it's funny because i mean
i've built built houses but
not like this because when i've built
houses it's been
for investment yeah because this is
yours it's like
it's massive i think i feel like i i
want it but i want to do it again
but it won't be that that little bit of
detail where i'm like
it's got to be there but yeah just do
that you know i mean for that to save
that little bit more money but we're
waiting here
it's like wow we can we will yeah
anything we're living there
is it is it like looking like a budget
or have you gone over on a lot of stuff
massively not massively managed to pull
back in certain areas what like
what went essential but one thing that
killed was what we weren't aware of
obviously being first is the steel
the steel man that
didn't tell us about conservatives
[Music]
[Music]
so what's the what's this what's this
how many square how many square feet or
square meters
3900
down
[Applause]
be aware of the work they're putting in
and get a little bit of an understanding
for me yeah
so they can so i've got an idea if
you've got a background in in the
in the industry at all no no no i guess
you're a footballer
yeah i
[Applause]
you need a hot tub in the garden bro
yeah we're gonna go around here
somewhere
yeah the sun hits from 10 and it's here
so like
great music so private
yeah you've got a bit of community yeah
yeah there's other houses
real smart obviously we struggle for
space but yeah it's something that
we've always wanted and to be quite
honest not saying it was when
but was it was it was turkey when we
were in that resort and i was
and i put on the instagram anyone
recommend
property guys or books or podcasts that
i wanted to listen around the pool you
always got recommended a lot i remember
telling you as well yeah
and uh i was just listening to that and
every because every house we were going
to visit because we were going to buy
somewhat where were like i don't like
this room i want to knock that wall down
i'd want to change that
so i basically said well [ __ ] it let's
buy let's buy some lines she was like
well
let's do it like like and we were
looking for a yeah and we're speaking to
people
driving out countrysides trying to get
private
and we got a call for this this was the
last one believe it or not available
who sold them was it like a developer
that sold it the guide him
he bought it all um and he like
he just yeah he sold it to us and
obviously he saw
all these but everything i wouldn't say
it was made easy for us but everything
was in like the services we're all in
already and you wanted to planning yeah
yeah we just needed to change what he
got planning for yeah oh you changed it
a bit yeah yeah well
completely yes what was it before it was
wasn't as complicated as this in terms
of the steel in the glass
yeah uh it was more of a more
traditional instead of
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
we're trying to make it up here
something a little bit different but
like you said it's not who is going to
be up here when we've got visitors i
mean we could come couldn't well
[Music]
wow outside balcony
when we sat down which is why all this
steel
is custard yeah yeah it's tight
do you want to try bro
he said it's too tight he says he says
he's too tight for me
let's find out put him to the test
have you been working already locked up
yeah so much space man
easy
i'll wait for this one anymore
that's more private and bigger well we
can
maybe do it again but with a better
understanding
in your own gated area that would be the
next step
we always want to live in middlesbrough
yeah
i think sawyer because she's got her own
business a dance school oh yeah so mills
was saying
she's got like almost 70 students there
where she needs to be pretty hands-on
with that
everything well like modern ballet
oh wow so yeah she's uh that's where our
business is obviously man's
all online so it's quite mobile but
yeah i've got a lot of family here so i
think so yeah
like so i was always in london london
lost a living and everything
bought a car from cash 10 yeah but
probably the biggest lesson on that but
the worst thing in terms of
the hell of it because it wasted 10
grand then from then on i was like right
needs to be invested in the better work
in that car
so that's it folks the beautiful five
bed mansion that's being built
congratulations guys what's been the
biggest lesson
throughout this process biggest lesson
for me is
finding a trustworth a team that you can
trust basically
someone uh who knows who you can trust
on the job along the way while you're
working with them
yeah and what what was the reason you
guys decided to like project manage this
yourself and not employ a project
manager
for me it was for a reason it's
something that interests me and i want
to do again
uh not as part as well as saving a lot
of money on it but it's something that
really interests me again
that it's not i want to do it again
basically so i needed to be involved in
hands-on to learn
okay do you want to learn on the job
learn while you earn
yes were you pleased with how how stand
out
in terms of what figures the process
also the figures we got the land for 250
uh we did thought we'd try and get there
were 350 but we've
been home that we're moving in as a
dream home we went top spec
with a lot of you know spiral stairs a
lot of glass a lot of steel
uh glass balconies bedroom terraces roof
terraces
so like i said top spec and we're
looking to spend 400 and total so 650
we've had a value just under a mill so
that's crazy though
just hear that bought the land for 250
spending 400 on it
and then the end value is just shy of a
million that's like hundreds of
thousands of pounds of profit
and a dream home yeah why property why
did you because i remember you didn't
even come to the crash clubs
you were there you came to the crash
course and enrolled on advanced training
what was it about property that that
really why did you want to get into
property
your background is football you played
for middlesbrough you're a model you're
an influencer
why property uh the figures
yeah basically we wanted to buy a house
and everybody else we went and looked at
it was a
we it was something i didn't like about
or we didn't like about it that i wanted
to change
and when speaking to more people and
connecting with people like yourself
learning how much learn more about the
figures of the housing
houses we were viewing yeah what they
were really where from what we were
paying
we thought well why can't we do this
ourselves and cut all that money out
what we could be losing
yeah we could be working there we go so
guys you'll expect to see me back i'll
be coming back when it's all done
i'll be staying in the top floor with
the balcony i'll be staying there i'll
be having dinner we'll be doing videos
do me a favor if you enjoyed the video
if you want to support leon and melissa
smash like also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel you can
subscribe up here
if you want to see more videos like this
you can check them out right here and i
look forward to seeing you guys
next time
[Music]
you